young people are finding it increasingly
difficult to get work the European
Social Fund is stepping in at all levels
to improve their chances to study train
and work it starts early
es F projects aimed to ensure all
children can get quality education
regardless of social standing or origin
other projects improve education systems
and update teacher skills and knowledge
extra attention is paid to supporting
children at risk of dropping out or
those who left school early without
qualifications many ESL projects help
make the transition into work easier for
example through work placements or
apprenticeships that provide the
practical skills employers demand and
for those who prefer to go to learn
there is help for setting up a business
training equips them with the right
skills and a small loan can get things
started the ESF can also fund projects
helping young people to study train and
work abroad to open up new opportunities
all these activities further the --use
goal of giving the young jobless a
concrete opportunity within four months
these are concrete solutions that offer
them the chance to develop their
potential and find a job the European
Social Fund investing in people